you are now graduates
sir you don't need it anymore throw them
doesn't matter however
before this gets out of hand I do have a
few brief remarks to make oh nice I
think that was a new record
congratulations again to all of you and
to the parents and families for the
support and love you've given your
children these past four years it's
truly a wonderful day for you too you
have every right to be proud of your
children who have accomplished something
important here and I want to thank you
also for entrusting your children to us
for the past four years they've
contributed much to this university and
we're grateful for that and
congratulations to you the class of 2010
it's been a real pleasure to have to
have had you here for the last four
years four years that have been
interesting and in some respects
challenging your first year your
freshman year was a relevant quiet one
the movies smart people was filled lone
campus and remember that it brought a
little glamour to our daily lives with
the likes of Sarah Jessica Parker and
dennis quaid and Thomas Haden Church
roaming campus the major controversy on
campus that year was choosing an
official mascot for the University after
prolonged debate and deliberation and
noting that the Scottie dog had been the
unofficial mascot for as long as anybody
could remember and even having a Scottie
dog costume we made national news by
naming our official mascot you're right
the Scottie dog I have to say Maggie the
real Scottie dog is really cute but
she's a ham man you see her sucking up
literally to some of you it was really
something to behold that was your
freshman year the beginning of your
sophomore year was interrupted seemingly
on a daily
cases by bomb scares and water main
breaks thankfully none of those
incidents was serious they did cause
disruption but at least we had some
excellent real-time tests of our new
emergency notification system in
September Randy Pausch delivered his
last lecture a funny moving and
inspiring 90 minutes of advice to all of
us at Carnegie Mellon and as it turned
out the world the video of Randy's talk
went viral leading to widespread media
coverage and eventually the book by
Randy and Jeff zaslow another Carnegie
Mellon alumnus Randy died this summer
after your sophomore year he was at home
surrounded by his family his legacy is
recognized by the bridge connecting
computer science and drama and a spirit
lives on in all of us also that year
Bill Gates chose our campus for the last
stop of his farewell tour and we hosted
presidential campaign events that
included John McCain Michelle Obama and
over the summer Barack Obama the big
story of your junior year was the
national election in which you
participated in historic numbers and of
course the election itself produced an
historic result he would seem that your
time here though built to a crescendo in
this year senior year after we got over
and passed the swine flu we had quite a
third week of September we dedicated a
new gates Hillman centers with Bill
Gates back on campus and of course we
hosted the g20 summit of global leaders
here in Pittsburgh Luke Ravenstahl who
became Pittsburgh's mayor during the
first week of your freshman year was
reelected in November two days later he
proposed a tax on your tuition
you organized very quickly and
coordinated with the other colleges and
universities in Pittsburgh and your
intelligence and respectful protest had
a very big impact in convincing the
mayor and the City Council to etre this
proposal and then the earthquake that is
worth applause and then the earthquake
hit Haiti of course Ian Ross ins story
may make us hesitant to talk about what
we did here and allow me a little
digression in this regard which also
provides a lesson many years ago in 1991
I was in Moscow while there was still a
Soviet Union as luck would have it I
arrived the night before a coup the
leader Mikhail Gorbachev was arrested
and a band of eight politicians took
over remarkably to me anyhow not a
single russian with whom i interacted
took this seriously indeed not a single
one of my scheduled meetings was
cancelled or delayed there were tanks in
the streets lots of tanks but there was
little violence still flying out or even
making calls to the US was impossible
the coup just sort of collapsed after
three days you know and I found myself
on a flight from Paris to New York
having gotten out of Moscow on Air
France's first flight since the coup had
started I struck up a conversation with
a man sitting next to me basically so I
could brag about my heroic death-defying
escape from Moscow tanks in the streets
oh it was horrible after completing my
tail I asked him what he did he answered
and you have to imagine the French
accent
I am the war correspondent for Lamont I
have covered many wars I've been shot at
dozens of times and wounded three times
I changed seats so what's the moral of
this story I know you're thinking be
modest don't brag and that is a good
moral but actually the real moral is
never and I mean never talk to strangers
on a plate so Ian with my deepest
respect and aberration what you've done
and continue to do for the people of
haiti let me brag just a little bit
about our students this class typical of
what you've done during your time here
there were no urging or prompting or
help from the administration students
you quickly organized to raise money and
they collect goods like blankets and
coats which were in short supply in
Haiti and you're doing it even today you
show great compassion and care for the
human suffering that you knew was being
experienced in Haiti it was admirable
and fully consistent with what we've
come to expect from your class
throughout your four years here it
became involved an important local
national and even international events
and you made a difference you handle
challenges on campus like bomb scares
and swine flu and I have to add
Snowmageddon
with poise and patience even your fun
activities were exceptional Spring
Carnival is always a highlight of the
year but i thought this year's was
simply terrific especially the booze
which I thought were very well done
scotch and soda and the Tartan two of
the oldest and richest traditions here
have thrived under your leadership as
have student government most of the
fraternities and sororities and almost
all of our student organizations you've
been a great class it's classes like
yours to remind us why we as teachers
and staff love what we do and why we
love Carnegie Mellon I was talking to a
couple of faculty members on Friday the
incoming and outgoing chairs of Faculty
Senate as I listened to them I was
reminded of another reason why I love
this university and what makes this
place special here were two outstanding
scholars leaders in their fields who are
debating how to assess the effectiveness
of our teaching how can we know that our
students you have learned what you need
to learn and are prepared for all the
challenges and opportunities that will
confront you when you walk out of this
stadium it was very reaffirming for me
to listen to them they displayed the
kind of deep interest in care that we
hope faculty will have at every
University but not every university does
Carnegie Mellon is a research university
of course or an institution grounded on
the principle that research should
inform education and vice versa we
believe the faculty who are actively
working at the frontiers of knowledge
will bring something to the classroom
that mirror teachers could not it's not
only the latest knowledge
they also bring a style a mindset of
questioning the status quo this is so
important for repairing you to be the
architects of change we want you to be
to an unusual degree are very research
intensive faculty are engaged in
undergraduate teaching their
accessibility to students and their care
for you have been noted by you in every
class that has come before you my
conversation on Friday also reminded me
about how innovative this university is
we're not just working at the frontiers
of academic disciplines are also
actively engaged in creating new ways to
educate and to learn we question the
status quo in everything we do and the
history of Carnegie Mellon has been one
educational innovation after another
from from granting the first degree in
drama more than 80 years ago creating
creating the first academic industrial
design program in 1934 and creating the
Carnegie plan in the 1940s which
conceived of the then radical idea that
engineers should learn about economics
and other social sciences the humanities
and communication skills you're supposed
to cheer engineers
thank you to the founding in 1949 of GSA
now the tepper school of business which
completely transformed the idea of
business education and created the field
of management science here was created
the field of computer science the first
department then the first school we
initiated research and artificial
intelligence invented human-computer
interaction created that was pretty lame
but that's all right
all right come on don't lose your sense
of humor almost done after inventing
human-computer interaction we created
the first Department of machine learning
and computational biology and the
biggest baddest academic organization in
robotics in the world every one of our
other colleges has their own first or
only or best programs the Heinz College
the melon college of science Hsss I
can't name them all but they have been
and continue to be leaders in
architecture change in the world of high
education this is the institution from
which you come the place where you've
learned and have prepared for the future
this is a legacy of fearless innovation
a legacy that is your legacy notice that
I said innovation and not invention some
of you no doubt will invent things and I
hope you do and I fully expect that some
of you will win Nobel prizes and medals
of Science and Technology joining other
Carnegie Mellon winners like dr. Bell
and dr. Denard about what but while we
all may not be inventors we can all be
innovators no matter where we work or
live or what we do the innovations may
not be big and transformative like the
ones that Miss literacy and dr. Simon's
have brought to the world but in their
own way and although I have no doubt
that some of them will be big in their
own way your innovations no matter how
big they are will make the world a
better place whether you find yourself
in a classroom or on a trading floor in
a laboratory or on a stage or staring at
a blank canvas remember that you are
better trained than anybody in the world
call on your experiences of work
in teams and interacting with and caring
about people very different from
yourselves love what you're doing don't
be afraid to show your passion for the
task at hand allow yourself in the same
way we've encouraged you to think
broadly and try new things calling on
all your all your own talents and those
brought by the people around you think
about what you're doing and why you're
doing it who will care about it who will
benefit from it and who will be hurt by
it in the end you will made a
contribution and in a way usually small
but occasionally big you'll have made
your part of the world better we expect
big things from you and we're confident
that you will do well and that we will
be proud of you as we are today you have
distinguished yourselves here and we'll
be watching carefully and with pride as
you make the world a better place you
the wonderful class of 2010 thank you
and congratulations
you